>> WELCOME AMERICA THIS IS THE
HOME OF POSITIVE POPULISM,
PRO-WORKER, PRO-FAMILY,
PRO-COMMUNITY, AND ESPECIALLY
PRO-AMERICA. ON THIS LABOR DAY
WEEKEND SPECIAL START BY
FOCUSING ON THE PRO- WORKER
PART.
LISTEN TO THE COMMANDER IN
CHAOS WITH HIS HAPLESS
SPOKESPERSON IS NOT EVEN
PREPARED.
>> HERE IS WHERE WE ARE.
WE HAVE THE FASTEST GROWING
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
THE WORLD.
>> WHEN WE LOOK AT WHERE WE
ARE ECONOMICALLY AND WE ARE A
STRONGER ECONOMICALLY WE HAVE
BEEN IN HISTORY.
STEVE: HISTORIC.
BEST IN THE WORLD.
MAYBE IN THEIR WORLD BUT NOT
IN THE REAL WORLD IT IS THE
REALITY THIS LABOR DAY WEEKEND
JOE BIDEN AMERICA IS WORKING.
YES IT IS TRUE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS LOW BUT
THE MAIN REASON THE RATE IS
LOW BECAUSE SO MANY AMERICANS
STOPPED LOOKING FOR WORK JUST
THIS WEEK WE SAW THE LATEST
FIGURES FOR JOB OPENINGS WAY
AHEAD OF EXPECTATION NEARLY AN
ALL-TIME RECORD SPINNING THIS
WITH GOOD NEWS PEOPLE ARE
HIRING.
NO.
THEY CANNOT FIND PEOPLE TO DO
THE WORK ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE HAVE RUNAWAY INFLATION.
LOOK AT THIS WE KEEP FOCUSING
ON THIS BECAUSE IT IS SO
IMPORTANT THE LABOR
PARTICIPATION RATE IS STILL
THE LOWEST OUTSIDE OF THE
PANDEMIC SHUT DOWN FOR 45
YEARS IS JUST OVER 60 PERCENT
THAT MEANS 40 PERCENT OF
AMERICANS OF WORKING AGE ARE
NOT WORKING.
THAT'S NOT JUST AN ECONOMIC
DISASTER BUT SOCIAL DISASTER
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN
HAVING A JOB FOR THE MOST
IMPORTANT BUILDING BLOCKS OF
THE HELP HAPPY AND FLOURISHING
LIFE BATTLE FOR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AND OUR ENTIRE
COUNTRY BUT HALF OF THE ADULTS
IN AMERICA ARE NOT WORKING.
WHY?
PART OF THE ANSWER IS REVEALED
IN A FASCINATING STUDY
PUBLISHED THIS WEEK BY FORMER
SENATOR GRAHAM.
WITH A SHOW IS BEHIND THE
OFFICIAL STATISTICS AFTER YOU
TAKE ACCOUNT OF WELFARE
BENEFITS RECEIVED IN TAXES
PAID THE INCOME OF THE BOTTOM
60 PERCENT OF AMERICA IS
ALMOST THE SAME WHICH YOU
WOULD THINK IS OKAY IF INCOME
INEQUALITY IS A PROBLEM.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
IT TURNS OUT WITHIN THAT GROUP
THERE IS A HUGE DIFFERENCE WHO
IS WORKING AND WHO IS NOT.
FROM THE BOTTOM 20 PERCENT OF
THE POPULATION 36 PERCENT ARE
WORKING NEXT 20 PERCENT
85 PERCENT ARE EMPLOYED THE
MIDDLE 20 PERCENT OF THE WHOLE
POPULATION NEARLY A EVERYBODY
IS WORKING BUT YET ALL THREE
OF THESE GROUPS ARE PRETTY
MUCH THE SAME INCOME.
IT IS A STAGGERING FINDING IF
YOU END UP MAKING THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY IF YOU WORK OR
NOT IS NOT SURPRISING MANY
PEOPLE WOULD NOT FROM
90 MILLION AMERICANS ARE NOT
ACTUALLY WORKING SOME CAN'T
WORK FOR VERY GOOD REASONS AND
A COMPASSIONATE SOCIETY WE
MUST HELP AND SUPPORT THEM IN
SOME THAT CHOOSE NOT TO WORK
IN THE ECONOMY A MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT WORK OF RAISING A
FAMILY WE SHOULD NOT MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT WHICH PARENT
STAYS HOME IN WHICH GOES OUT
TO WORK.
BUT WE ALL KNOW FROM OUR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WE HAVE
MANY PEOPLE WHO COULD WORK AND
SHOULD WORK BUT THE CUSHION OF
STAY-AT-HOME SUBSIDIES IF
TODAY WE HAVE LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION ANOTHER
20 MILLION AMERICANS WOULD BE
WORKING.
HOW DO WE MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION?
FOR START WE CAN RUN THE
ECONOMY WITH TRUMP THE AVERAGE
EARNINGS TAKING ACCOUNT OF
INFLATION WAS UP
EIGHT.7 PERCENT UNDER BIDEN
THEY HAVE FALLEN MORE THAN
5 PERCENT THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE
BUT BEYOND THAT WE NEED A PRO-
WORKER POLICY AGENDA FOR REAL
AND WITH ANY ECONOMIC PROBLEM
IT BREAKS DOWN INTO SUPPLY AND
DEMAND ME TO BRING BACK JOBS
FROM CHINA PRESIDENT TRUMP LED
THE WAY WITH THE DECADES LONG
ESTABLISHMENT CONSENSUS TO
HOLLOW OUT THE HEARTLAND AND
IT DID NOT MATTER NOW IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION WITH
TYPICAL INCOHERENCE USING THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT TO
BOOST JOBS IN CHINA AND
PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANT IS
INCREASING THE SUPPLY THAT
MEANS DROPPING OUR COSTLY AND
SELF-DESTRUCTIVE OBSESSION
WITH SENDING EVERY YOUNG
AMERICAN TO WORK
INDOCTRINATION FACTORIES ALSO
KNOWN AS UNIVERSITIES AND
EQUIPPING THE NEXT GENERATION
WITH THE SKILLS THEY NEED TO
BE PRODUCTIVE WORKERS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ENTERPRISE
ECONOMY TRUMP UNDERSTOOD THIS
A BIG AND APPRECIATED EFFORT
WE COVERED IT HERE.
>> CULTURALLY FOR A LONG TIME
TO PERPETUATE A NARRATIVE THAT
HAS GONE HALFWAY TO ACHIEVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
OPENED TO SAY WHAT IT IS IN
YOUR LIFE AND THEN TO TAKE THE
STIGMA AWAY FROM THOSE WHO
CHOOSE ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
ABOUT CONNECTING WORKERS WITH
THEIR PASSION AND WITH THEIR
JOB.
STEVE: AMERICANS NEED TO MAKE
THIS A PRIORITY TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT ENDING
UNJUSTIFIED GOVERNMENT STAY AT
HOME SUBSIDIZED BOOSTING
MANUFACTURING EQUIPPING
AMERICANS WITH THE SKILLS AND
TRAINING THEY NEED BUT THE
DECADES FOR DEMOCRATS THAT
THEY WERE THE WORKERS PARTY
BUT IF THE ELITIST WOKE
ACTIVIST TOOK OVER THEY
ADOPTED THE ANTI- WORKER
AGENDA DESTROYING ENERGY JOBS
DESTROYING BLUE-COLLAR
EARNINGS WITH LOW-WAGE
MIGRATION DESTROYING THE
LIVING STANDARDS WITH
INFLATION IN DEALING WITH THE
WORKING CLASS TO BAILOUT THE
RICH COLLEGE CLASS.
SO NOW WE CAN SEE WHAT WE'VE
BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS THE GOP
IS BECOMING A MULTIRACIAL
WORKING CLASS WHILE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE THE PARTY OF THE
RICH A